love it or hate it the first season of
halo has come to an end with paramount
already renewing the series for season
two are those sad tissues or happy
tissues this show has received a lot of
controversy from master chief losing his
virginity later than i did i didn't know
that was possible to characters who seem
totally disconnected from the main
storyline
all that aside we're gonna take a deep
dive into the ending and explain some of
the show's biggest unanswered questions
so charge up your sticky grenades and
command your army of penis worms because
here we go this is master chief the
leader of silver team a task force
composed of super soldiers called
spartans under the command of the united
nations space command kind of like our
u.n but way cooler it is said that one
spartan is the equivalent of a hundred
marines so these guys are considered a
valuable asset chief's real name is john
one of the most generic names you can
give but that's the point master chief
isn't supposed to have his own
personality emotions or even make his
own choices he's supposed to be a
mindless killing machine tasked only
with following orders in fact he and the
other spartans are implanted with
hormonal pellets which suppress their
emotions it's ironic then that he's
fighting to save humanity when he
himself has lost many of the aspects
that make him human in the first place
jon's transformation into this super
soldier began at a young age throughout
the season we'll see john unlock
memories from his past memories which
were wiped from his mind originally he
was told his parents died of a plague on
the planet eridanus ii and then was
adopted by dr catherine halsey for the
spartan program this was a lie after
touching a mysterious artifact it
unlocks a memory of him being kidnapped
as a child unbeknownst to his parents
his body was replaced with a clone one
that would die shortly after via deadly
seizures under halsey's orders dozens of
children were secretly replaced with
these defective clones so that she could
have her pick of young easy
manipulatable spartan proteges on the
other side of the galaxy we have another
character who was similarly manipulated
and brainwashed at a young age this is
mckee who as a child saw the cruelty of
humanity when she was essentially a
slave laborer under unsc command it's
only when her planet was attacked by the
covenant an alien race hell-bent on
destroying humanity that it's discovered
she's a quote-unquote blessed one being
capable of activating ancient artifacts
that are critical in the covenant
religion she is brought under the
protection of mercy the eldest of three
leaders in the covenant high council
under his tutelage she learns of the
great journey a journey that will lead
the covenant to the sacred ring where
they will become gods of course the
great journey can't be completed without
a map and that's where these ancient
artifacts known as keystones come in
analysis of the keystone found on the
planet magical reveals them being over a
hundred thousand years old predating
humans and possibly even the covenant
it's likely that these keystones were
created by the forerunners an ancient
species worshiped by the covenant these
ring-like installations were created by
them as weapons against the flood a
parasitic alien race so both mckee and
master chief have some sort of ancestral
connection to the keystones the two of
them the only beings who can activate
its power even as a child john drew
pictures of the keystones this is how he
knew that two keystones needed to be
joined together to create the whole just
like how mckee and master chief will
literally join together while making
love the final episode is called
transcendence which makes sense
considering both the covenant and dr
halsey believe they can transcend their
respective species if they are able to
get a hold of this sacred ring dr halsey
believes that humanity is deeply flawed
and needs to transcend in order to save
it from itself
that's why they need us cortana
to save them from themselves it's almost
as if she wants to make humanity just
like her spartans devoid of emotion and
she's willing to go to great lengths to
do this even kidnapping and murdering
dozens of children as long as it's for
the good of mankind you kidnapped
mutilated and murdered dozens of
children to save billions more saving
humanity at the cost of your own master
chief is stuck between all these
competing parties the covenant who want
to destroy humanity the unsc who want to
control him and the spartans and dr
halsey who wants to use the ring for her
own twisted idea of how humanity should
evolve when master chief initially
touches the artifact it produces a ring
a ring which wreth calls a door to the
end of life both halsey and master chief
believe this to be a weapon one that can
be used to defeat the covenant mckee was
initially sent to the humans as a sort
of trojan horse tasked with infiltrating
the humans and retrieving the keystone
they acquired on madrigal but when she
meets jon the two form a connection and
for a brief moment she joins his side
this is symbolized when she removes the
covenant energy blade she had implanted
in her fingernail but this switching of
sides is short-lived when she is
brutally tased while in captivity which
conjures images from her past she has
these taser scars from when she was a
child an event which instilled in her
her hatred for humanity so she's able to
escape with the keystone and make it
back to the covenant the tragedy of
mckee however is that for all she's done
for the covenant they secretly want to
rid themselves of her
whether she realizes it or not she has
no home perhaps this is why she so
desperately wants to stay on that planet
with a sacred ring the unsc not only has
to deal with mckee escaping but also dr
hulsey you can tell they have top-notch
security here even though she's
eventually apprehended by a spartan
known as kai we find out this escapee is
actually a clone this was all a smoke
screen so the real halsey could get off
planet the end of the episode we'll see
her writing in a journal at the reach
heritage site of manassas a city on
planet reach which has its own spaceport
in this journal we can make out what
appears to be a brain scan and a drawing
of cortana who knows what research and
data halsey smuggled with her and how
this will affect season 2. the finale
takes place at a holy covenant temple in
the aspro system a location master chief
and the spartans decide to infiltrate
via stealth rather than bring in the
entire unsc fleet mckee had mentioned to
master chief in a prophecy that the halo
was meant to be revealed where the stars
sparkle like glass and it just so
happens there's only one place in the
aspro system where gravity warps light
in such a way where it sparkles like
glass that's how master chief's able to
narrow down the location of the covenant
at the same time cortana reveals to
master chief that halsey's original plan
was for her to completely take over his
mind and body this will become important
later on when the spartan's infiltration
is discovered and a giant battle ensues
the spartans are completely outnumbered
we're talking hundreds to one plus
there's this dude who if we're to
believe cg artist mahmoud salah who
worked on the animation for him is
atriox a big villain in the halo
universe we first saw him in episode 5
when he steals a keystone from the
humans on a redness 2. mckee sees chief
pummeled by atriox and in an effort to
save him touches the fully combined
keystone which sets off an explosive
energy blast more importantly it reveals
a star map with the location to the
sacred ring the full map however is
incomplete when mckee is shot by kai
leaving only master chief with the
ability to activate the stones this is
why the high council is so pissed when
atriox kills master chief as this would
make finding the sacred ring now wholly
impossible and this event may be the
beginning of his separation from the
covenant in the games atriox leads a
group of covenant who join forces with
the unsc with the spartans on the
defensive and their time surely
outnumbered master chief is left with
only one option for cortana to fully
take control even though cortana says
she may not be able to bring him back he
says he trusts her which is ironic since
in episode 2 he said there is no one he
could trust except dr halsey who cortana
is modeled after master chief flatlines
in cortana takes over and because jon
isn't in control of master chief anymore
it allows cortana to pick up the ancient
keystone without it going all haywire
with their aircraft acting as a shield
the spartans are able to make their
escape the keystone intact and you'll
notice from the moment cortana takes
control master chief doesn't have any
dialogue and it will be interesting to
see if this continues into season two
chi as if jon is really himself but is
met with no response we don't know if
cortana will be able to give jon control
back and perhaps the only way that's
possible is if jon is reunited with
halsey then there's mckee whose body was
left back at the covenant temple i'm not
100 convinced she's gone for good after
all in a world where humans can be
cloned it's possible we may see her come
back especially since halsey had likely
done tests on her but the biggest
question mark in all this comes from a
character who we didn't even see in the
last episode quan ha a person whose
storyline seemed like it was its own
show altogether the big thread left
behind in her story is a portal that was
hinted at in episode 7. while on her
vision quest of sorts she is told that
she and her ancestors are integral in
accessing this well which is actually a
portal fueled by the soil of madrigal
however its secrets won't be revealed
until madrigal is safe with the unsc
still in control of the planet it may
take master chief and the crew to join
forces with quan to access this portal
just where it leads we can't be sure so
that is where the show leaves us master
chief and the spartans have the artifact
the unsc and covenant are in disarray
mckee is dead and halsey on the run but
what did you think of halo does it
deserve the hate or a season 2 let me
know in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time
win the remember